why do we need to be reminded why do you
feel we need to be reminded that it's
important to do good um I think it's a
great question my mom though I think I
think actually Evans hit a nail there
with the stigma and I think actually the
other thing if I when I was in Montreal
a couple of months ago you know I picked
up the papers from the hotel and from
page was about actually greedy business
people exactly to pay stuff like that I
think there's there's just an
overwhelming level of noise to depict
entrepreneur's sometimes is the bad
gardener I just think that's so far from
the truth and therefore the more we
remind ourselves and actually
communicate the amazing things you guys
do if you do this you should be so proud
of what you do in terms of working in
the community to make a difference I
just think it's something that is worth
shouting about and with a sense of
humility never any arrogance but I think
it is something that you should be very
proud of so it's good to remind
ourselves that this is important I think
a lot of people as I said on this plant
will be with preaching to convert it
because you guys will get it and that's
probably why you're joining the glare
but we need to spread the love and
there's a lot of people out there who
probably depict a stereotypical
entrepreneur it's just going to greedy
private jets you know try the island 15
houses you know Ferraris and all that
sort of stuff I don't think that could
be from the truth maybe there's one or
two or less than one person but I think
mostly wonderful as I know and me I just
want to built on a very special pursue
their passions be their own boss I have
that great sense of Independence and
build something as a legacy but also
doing the right way and make a mess of
different nickname fits or pursue their
passion about fitting that well arm on
the who asked the question wrote yes
good point Stephen so I think you
answered that for him um what I would
add to it too i think is uh i think
sometimes we just get caught up in life
like running a business is hard and it's
a ton of you guys know it's a ton of our
time and effort to get our business off
the ground and sometimes we lose we lose
sight of some of the things that are
important right sometimes we need to be
reminded spend time with our spouses or
boyfriends or girlfriend or we need to
spend time with our kids or we need to
remember what our mission is ourselves
simply get so locked into the daily
grind of doing and executed in making
payroll and all the stresses that you
have that sometimes you just need an
outside perspective that breath of fresh
air to remind you about the things that
are truly important entrepreneur you
guys work hard sometimes something is
good we almost like run on autopilot and
I also come back to the food bank the
next day I was so invigorated I will
always go up in the office with a spring
in my step and I'm wildly optimistic and
happy about life but that day I was I
floated it charity I floated it and if
though I hadn't reminded myself to do a
bit of volunteering you get into it you
get into a wrap and it's almost like
having a holiday if you had a three-day
break you catch up on your sleep you
connect reconnect with your partner your
kids and stuff like just in green sea I
think I think great on for those high
could come and it really supports great
Dharma and sometimes it's so easy just
to be kind of head down running a
thousand miles an hour so its proper you
remind yourself it's time to recommit
ourselves to you the wider community